let's go ahead and send it over to
madison kimbrough now she has the latest
on this entire event and its impact on
our city madison
yeah what a fun event this weekend take
a look at the strip right now it is
packed with runners a way to really
participate in this marathon today the
half marathon took place on the strip
passing iconic sites such as the welcome
to las vegas sign the fountains of
bellagio and finishing mid-strip at the
volcano at the mirage hotel and casino
here's what some people who traveled to
vegas just for the race had to say
it's my first time in vegas running this
one it's great it's exciting
can't ask for better weather it's been a
long time since i've done one coven kind
of cut out running for a lot of people
many people out here expressing their
gratitude for the run to be back in
action as many missed the large crowd
atmosphere that this marathon brings
again runners will finish up at the
mirage this started around 4 30 as
runners were lining up and we have been
seeing them go constantly up and down
the strip they're going to end again at
the mirage and they have until about 10
p.m so we have some advanced runners
here that have already made it through
some are walking some are jogging it's
great to be out here reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now